hi this is presh talwalkar let's discuss
the scientific way to remove eggs from a
carton
there's a very common problem when you
have a carton of eggs people will
haphazardly remove the eggs from
different sides
leaving a very unusual distribution and
it could end up wobbly
so we're going to come up with some
solutions
the first solution is to remove the eggs
from the opposite corners
the result will be a balanced weight
distribution that's steady in the center
so we'll remove one egg from one corner
and then remove the egg from the
opposite corner switching side by side
at any point the center of gravity will
be in the center and the weight will be
balanced evenly from the center
this is very good if you want to grab
the egg carton from the center
a second solution
is that you should remove the eggs only
from one side
the reason is that when you put an egg
carton in the fridge you typically will
grab it just from one side
so if we remove the eggs from the left
side of the carton
it'll actually be very easy to grab the
egg carton from the right side all of
the weight will be concentrated on the
right
and you just keep removing eggs from one
side until you're taking all the eggs
out
a third solution is a balanced approach
between these two
you might imagine people are grabbing
the egg carton from different sides
and you want to make sure it's
balanced and the weight is spread out so
this solution
will be a little more complicated to
execute
at any stage when we're removing the
eggs the weight will be distributed so
the center of mass is in the center of
the carton
but we will also have
a balanced weight
so you'll have to pay attention
carefully with how the eggs are removed
once we get to six eggs it's a very even
and neat distribution you can pick it
from any side
then we're going to remove eggs from the
opposite sides
here we have four eggs it's a very
symmetrical view when we get down to
three eggs we're going to have to make
an adjustment we move two of the eggs in
so
the carton is less wobbly and then we
move the final egg to the center
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel you can support
me on patreon
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
on twitter at preshtalwalker
and you can get my books